the debate got spicy
fast and then it got even spicier Mr
Vice President to give Russia theyve got
Mr vice president with eight candidates
dramatically lagging in polls to an
indicted former president who didn't
even bother to show up the first
Republican presidential debate of the
2024 campaign season began as a rolling
brawl and continued from there listen
we're getting control of the debate this
is a lightning round not rolling
thunder Florida Governor Ronda santis
leading the polls among those on stage
was expected to be the one with the
Target on his back my sole Focus will be
on your future and reversing this
country's decline but the candidate who
drew the most fire was often a
businessman described by some as
bombastic and charismatic and it wasn't
Donald Trump who the heck is this skinny
guy with a funny last name the last
person in one of these debates Brett who
stood in the middle of the stage and
said what's a skinny guy with an odd
last name doing up here was Barack Obama
and I'm afraid we're dealing with the
same type of amateur standing in Sage
tonight come over and give me a
hug give me a hug just like you did to
Obama same time and you'll help elect me
just like you did to Obama too he wants
to hand Ukraine to Russia he wants to
let China eat Taiwan he wants to go and
stop funding Israel and you are choosing
a murder o of for a pro American country
N I wish you well in your future career
on the boards of locked and Ron do you
want a super pack puppet or do you want
a patriot who speaks the truth do you
want incremental reform which is what
you're hearing about or do you want
Revolution it was a contrast of Youth
and experience I think if you're looking
for an outsider candidate VC
ramaswami won very easily if you're
looking for the political establishment
I think the the winner was Nikki Haley
because I think she effectively defended
foreign policy and she also did very
good job on the abortion question I'll
tell you who did a great job an absent
Trump appeared in an online interview
instead as some Rivals declared him
unfit to resume office we have to face
the fact that Trump is the most disliked
politician in America we can't win a
general election that
way when it was over the candidates
assessed themselves invariably favorably
did you achieve what you wanted to sir
well I thought it was a great night I
thought we had a vigorous debate about
the future of the Republican party and I
was able to make my case that I'm the
most uh experienced proven conservative
ready on day one to bring the kind of
leadership that will turn this country
around the debate will likely narrow the
field before the next round in September
it ended without a clear sign that any
of the candidates became a more
challenging rival to a former president
with a runaway lead in the polls John
hendin Al jazer
Milwaukee